[MUSIC]
Hello, everybody, welcome to
the Africa Business Club's Q&A for
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
My name is Ruth I am from Nigeria, and
I'm joined here today with
three amazing panelists.
So panelists, if you can
introduce yourself, say your name,
where you're from, and
what you hope to do after business school.
>> Cool, so my name is Kevin,
I'm from Uganda.
Before business school,
I was running a company back home,
worked with McKinsey for the summer, and
I'll be joining McKinsey after school.
>> Hi, everyone, thanks for dialing in.
My name is Eugene, I'm from Kenya.
Before the GSP, I was working for
the International Finance Corporation
in London.
And before that I worked for
an asset management firm in Nairobi and
after business school I'm hoping to work
in a private equity space in Africa.
>> Hello everyone, my name is Rami Day.
Before business school,
I was in McKinsey for three years.
I was working in the Lagos office for
two, and then in London for a year.
In business school,
I've actually transitioned a lot,
I've worked in space tech
over the summer in Global X.
And after business school,
I'm still not sure what I'm going to do,
whether I'm going to go back to Google or
stay at McKinsey.
>> Okay, and
now I'll also introduce myself.
Like I said, I'm Ruth, I'm from Nigeria.
I did public accounting
before business school,
as well as did some work on the continent
of Africa in different countries in
different capacities,
which we can get into a little bit later.
And after business school I am one of
those people who also has a few options.
I'll either do Big Tech or
do something on my own, but
it has to focus on emerging markets.
So as one of the co- presidents
of Africa Business Club,
I'm super excited to bring this
webinar out to you guys today.
Our lovely Stanford administrators
informed us that this has been a huge,
there have been huge signups for
this webinar with 300 people signed up.
So it does seem like we have a ton
of people from the continent or
connected to the continent
of Africa in some way,
who are interested in life as
African students at the GSB.
So I'm super excited for you guys to
have a conversation with you guys.
So, one is asked one first question,
so when did you guys decide to apply for
Stanford?
And what made you guys choose
Stanford over other schools?
Anybody can go first.
>> Okay, I'll go first.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well,
I think I decided to apply to Stanford,
perhaps one year before I applied.
And so I had lived and worked in
Europe for almost three years and
I thought it would be great to
actually come study in the US and
also have a bit of an American experience
before returning to work in the continent.
The reason I chose Stanford is because I
wanted a school that was really committed
to the African continent.
And I think over the last five or
so years,
we've seen Stanford properly demonstrate
that more than any other school.
I happen to interact with
the Stanford CIT program,
which is being run out of Nigeria,
out of Ghana and Kenya.
And I met some of the Stanford CIT alum,
I also met some of the students would come
in under the Stanford Africa Fellowship,
which I think is a strong
statement by Stanford.
They're actually really
committed in Africa's future.
So that made it more obvious choice.
>> I can go next.
I decided to fly in, instead I wanted to
come here in 2015 and the previous Dean
of Admissions, Derrick Bolton was
in Uganda talking about the GSP.
And to put it bluntly,
I fell in love after the talk.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And then started speaking to a bunch of
students, alums, and the main reason
I wanted to come here is people.
Just interacting with so
many people who are super impressive but
also down to earth and
genuinely kind people.
It was a place I wanted to be here,
everything else I thought was amazing,
curriculum school in general, but
it came for me, down to the people,
who I had spoken to and interacted with.
>> Right, and
just to build on what Kevin said, so
when I was thinking about
my business school.
As I said I was in McKinsey before,
and actually the Africa office had
a lot of people go do their MBA,
but no one had come to Stanford.
And when I was thinking of applying
to business school, I think for
me the biggest thing was I really
wanted to know myself more and
I wanted to be in a program that
allowed me to explore myself.
Exploring interpersonal dynamics and
Stanford is the kind of place where that
is encouraged and that is allowed and
you have the permission and almost
the support to go deeper into yourself.
So that was why I decided
to come to Stanford.
>> Amazing, thank you.
So, I do know personally,
all of you guys did not live in the United
States before you started Stanford.
I know you visited, but
you hadn't lived in the United States, so
I'm curious to understand how
that transition was for you guys,
[LAUGH] to the Bay Area and to Stanford?
>> I think it was surprisingly easy for me
compared to, I did my undergrad in the UK.
And it was super difficult for me to do
that transition from Canada to England,
but to the US, it was a lot easier.
It might be a function of age,
I came when I was 27, but
also I think it's a function
of the community here.
There's so many people willing to help you
understand what's happening on campus.
The second year was great, the Africa
Business Club, the Association, everyone I
interacted with was super helpful in
helping me adjust to living in the US.
And so I looking back, I should not have
had any worries of making a move here,
it was a pretty easy shift.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah, I think for me,
even though I went to school in the UK,
like the first few weeks it did
take some getting adjusted to.
So, all the cities I have lived
have been really big cities.
I lived in Lagos, I lived in London and
Palo Alto is very beautiful,
but it's a smaller city
compared to Lagos or London.
So that was a little bit of
a hard transition for me.
But what I would say is the African
community in Stanford is extremely strong,
so that served as a base of support,
of encouragement, while I
went through the transition and navigated
>> Anything for you?
I know you just started a few months ago,
so maybe you're still adjusting.
>> Yeah, I think, I just didn't want
to repeat what everyone has said but
I think it was really,
it was easier than I expected.
And that's just because, I think Stanford
dedicates a lot of resources to students,
and that makes a big transition
a really easy thing.
The only thing I struggled with
was taking a 16 hour flight.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> [LAUGH]
>> So that's pretty tough.
>> Yeah, that sounds tough.
So you guys have now spent over
one year each at Stanford, and
you've been here for a few months already.
I would love for you guys to just
discuss how being at Stanford has
changed the way you plan
to either work in Africa or
how you plan to impact
the continent of Africa?
>> I can go first, I think for
me the biggest shift, and
I don't think it was necessarily a shift,
I think it's just a reinforcement.
So coming into Stanford,
the two things that were important
to me were technology and Africa.
But I didn't really know how this two
merge and whether that means I'll start up
my own thing, that whether that
meant working Big Tech in Africa.
But being in Stanford given we're
in Silicon Valley, I will just.
Exposed to so much technology,
innovative technology, not so
innovative technology,
all sorts of technology.
I feel like I have a much better sense of
what technology in Africa means to me.
And those two parts of myself which
I thought were almost despaired
are coming together.
>> I think somewhat similar to what
Nlanda said, coming into Stanford I have
a FinTech background and all the things
I was thinking about were in FinTech,
all the ways to impact Africa for me was
how can FinTech change X and Y industry?
And so coming here and
interacting with people who've done so
many different things in different
industries for me was very eye opening.
And like now I'm looking at
things like election mobility,
which I had no idea I was
interested in before.
And so just being exposed to people,
not just the GSB, but
also other Stanford schools, has opened
up my mind to different opportunities
that I could leverage on the continent
in different industries.
>> I think for me, it's early days, but
probably one of the biggest differences
I'm noticing is in a lot of the spaces I
was in before, social impact is something
that people think about, you know,
after they've thought about
how much money they make.
And I think at Stanford, almost everyone
across the different graduate schools and
the students themselves,
I think people think of social impact
as not something mutually exclusive from
running a commercially viable business, so
I think almost everyone you meet at
Stanford is very conscious about
not just building a business, but
building a very sustainable business
that is, for the greater good.
>> Yeah, I love that, I think also for
me personally coming to Stanford has been
an amazing challenge in a good way
because we get to sit with 400 incredibly
intelligent people who think very
differently about how different problems
can be solved and your premonition, or
your previous ideas of how to change the
world are challenged each and every day.
And so for me personally, I can definitely
vouch for what these three guys have said
in terms of coming here, thinking I wanted
to change Africa a specific way, and
my specific way was through branding and
through products.
And then talking to different
people from athletes,
to people who were coming from
the entertainment industry,
to former entrepreneurs who've been very
successful, and just sitting with them and
brainstorming with them and
thinking through different problems.
And hearing them ask questions,
as people who may not have lived on the
continent, are not from the continent, but
are genuinely curious about Africa,
has just been a way for
me to synthesize information, understand
what I actually care about, and know that
it's extremely possible to pursue
whatever it is that you want to pursue.
And so that's been something
I loved about the GSB.
So I'll give one more question, so
you guys and the audience, you guys can
continue to type in your life questions.
I'm already seeing some
questions pop up here.
And then we'll take some questions
directly from the audience.
But the last question I wanted to ask
you guys before we give it over to
the audience is,
what have been some of your favourite
activities at the GSB, so far?
Could be fun, could be academic,
could be sleep.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I think for
me, it's been the Africans forum.
The culture that we landed
in was amazing experience.
Just showcasing what the content has
to offer to people on campus and also
interacting with so many business leaders,
academic leaders from the continent either
focused there or working in the US as
well was just amazing experience for me.
>> You know,
I think not to steal Kev's plan.
[LAUGH] But I think leading the African
Business Forum with Kev last year was
definitely a highlight for me.
And just to add something new,
I think we just have a unique
opportunity to almost be the conduit
between Silicon Valley and Africa.
And you find yourself bridging that gap
many times while leading the conference.
And that was just
an exciting opportunity for
me to expose business leaders in Africa
to what's happening in Silicon Valley,
I likewise expose people in Silicon Valley
to what's happening on the continent.
>> Did you have anything too?
>> Yeah, I think for me what I've
enjoyed most is there's a lot of
entrepreneurs around the Silicon Valley
that are investing in Africa and
for the African business club to be
able to bring these entrepreneurs
to campus every so often just to speak
to them, that has been quite impactful.
But I think yesterday night was one of
my favorite things on campus to see
like just the different talent we had
a sort of a bad night where people from
the business could get to showcase
their talent and I just did not have so
many classmates who were just-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah.
>> Musically gifted and to even see
Africans get on stage and sing and
get so much support from the crowd.
That was lovely.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, I think you guys
have said everything.
Funny enough, one of my favorite
parts of Stanford are the classes.
I know, [LAUGH] the classes
don't get a lot of love, but
specifically as an MBA too,
I love my classes,
like going to class, we do a lot of
role plays with just titans of industry.
Like the person teaching your VC class, or
your venture capital class is somebody who
has been in venture capital for years.
The person teaching your real estate class
is the CEO of, what, some of the largest
real estate, or one of the largest real
estate companies in the United States.
So that has just been very humbling for
me.
But also, I just can't believe every
single day that I get the opportunity
to learn from such amazingly talented and
accomplished people.
So that's one of my favorite
things about the GSB.
So now we'll take questions
from the audience.
So I'm going to,
hopefully I pronounce this correctly,
Borubafadzo Chidau wanted to ask you
a question, Kevin, and the question is,
you mentioned that you were
an entrepreneur before the GSB and
then you mentioned that you interned for
McKenzie and you plan to go back to
McKinsey, so what is the thinking behind
going from entrepreneurship to consulting,
because usually it's consulting
to entrepreneurship?
So, I started my own company right out of
undergrad and essentially teaching myself
everything on the job, and coming into
the GSB, I thought I was missing certain
skill sets that I thought large corporate
organisations, superstructured,
have massive training programs would
be great for me to learn from.
And also I did choose to go
to consulting at McKinsey.
I think I did learn quite
a bit over the summer and
I think there's value in me learning those
things for the next year, year and a half,
two years, and I think those will
be super valuable in my company.
But also like being brutally honest, if
you look at my resume, if you don't have
my companies, you will not have an idea of
if they're good or bad companies, right?
And there's a huge theorem put on
working organizations, like McKinsey or
other organizations, and I think for
me, there's value in doing that.
And sometimes people overlook that or
do understate it, but
I think that's quite important, even on
the continent, so I feel it was a way for
me to get the most for me.
>> Amazing.
Thank you.
We have Taban from Johannesburg, and
he wants to know, how do you go
about finding a mentor at the GSB?
>> I think that's a good question.
I think there are many different
places where you could find a mentor.
Actually, you'd be surprised that a lot of
your classmates could even act as mentors,
because now that I'm thinking actively
about potentially starting something after
business school, maybe in like a one year
horizon after graduating there are so
many founders in my class
who I'm looking to for
mentorship to be able to guide me on
the path of being a first time founder.
So that's one avenue, another avenue are
professors as Ruth was saying We're just.
It's so humbling to know the kind
of people who teach us classes on
a daily basis.
And give us access to their network,
give us access to all of their knowledge.
So I'm taking a class called Startup
Garage where I'm actually working on my
startup.
And the caliber of professors in
Startup Garage is just mind-blowing.
I mean, there's one of my professors,
who I think,
I'm not sure what the exact figure is.
But has invested in 13 of the unit.
And this is someone that
comes to class every day and
is actively helping us
build our business idea.
And that's also another avenue for
mentorship.
Those were the two that came to mind and
[INAUDIBLE] I was there, views.
>> I can add another avenue if
you're looking for scholarships,
it's the Knight-Hennessy Scholarship.
>> Yeah.
>> Is a good one to apply to because
I've personally been able to get
a very good mentor.
Who's an entrepreneur,
the scholarship has a large array
of members of the advisory board.
And many of them come from
very different industries, so
if you're admitted into the scholarship.
And there's an advisor who
sort of is interested in
the same things you're interested in.
Then they'll reach out and
provide you with mentorship.
>> I think one more avenue is the alumni.
>> Yeah.
>> I am pretty close to the person who
interviewed me to come to the JSB.
And you interact with so
many alumns over your time here and
you develop some deep relationships.
And I think that's another avenue you
could get some good mentors here.
>> Amazing, thank you guys.
So we'll have a question from
Warren from South Africa again.
And Warren wants to know if you found
it relatively easy when you entered
your internship for the summer.
So this is a question for and Kevin.
And so when you entered your
internship for the summer,
did you find it relatively
easy to get your first choice?
Or did you feel like you had to settle for
your second, third, maybe fourth choice.
>> Okay, I can go, and I would say
that my route for my internship,
I probably wouldn't recommend
in hindsight [LAUGH].
But I knew that I really,
really wanted to work for X.
I really wanted to work specifically for
one of the graduates at
X projects called Learn.
So essentially,
I put all of my eggs in one basket, and
I would not recommend that in hindsight.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] But
I just felt that my profile, I'd worked
in consulting, parts, business school.
I didn't have a profile
that might stand out to.
And I felt that I needed to put it in
a lot of work to prove that I wanted to
work there.
So what that meant for me was I
spent three months researching and
talking to people in
the aerospace department.
because it was space technology.
Immersing myself in space tech, and
I then did an outside game strategy for
Learn.
And all of that took a three-month period,
what that meant is I couldn't
apply to any other company.
So I'm just thinking in hindsight,
if it hadn't worked out.
I probably wouldn't have had
an internship over the summer,
so I don't recommend it,
but that was my journey.
>> But having privy to some of
your experiences last year,
also have worked extremely hard, guys.
She didn't just put it in the basket and
just let it sit there.
because I also know that you took computer
science classes which takes a lot of time,
specifically for
the schedule of the MBA student.
So you definitely put
the eggs in one basket, but
you made sure that your resume was
very strong by the end of the year.
>> Yeah, yeah, that's true, because
I knew I was only doing one company,
I literally gave it my all.
>> Yeah.
>> And I wanted my application to be
an application that would
at least get a call back.
Yeah, so it kind of worked out.
>> I might at the extreme
end of that spectrum,
where I came in with different
ideas of what I wanted to explore.
Consulting was definitely
very close to the top,
I flirted with the idea of investment
banking, venture capital, tech.
And I thought about applying to all these
these industries and all these companies.
And you're going to probably realize
like you can't devote as much time and
effort to apply to all these.
And your application will definitely
not stand out if you spreading
yourself too thin.
And so I focused on Consulting for
the internship, and yeah, I got McKinsey.
So I'm glad I did,
it was a great experience.
>> Amazing, so
we have a question from David which
I'm guessing is from Nigeria [LAUGH].
But the question says, asides from Paga,
can you please talk about
other startups that have been
founded by African Stanford alumn.
And can you spotlight some PE firms
in Africa that are doing some
interesting things to
develop the continent.
So Eugene, let you take the PE question,
and then after that, Kevin,
maybe you guys can talk about startups.
And running companies that you
know have been founded by alumn.
>> Okay, besides Paga I
think this NALA in Tanzania,
there is Savannah Fund
which is a VC in Kenya.
Zipline in Uganda,
I'm not sure if it's GSB alumns.
>> I think Stanford alumns-
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> In addition,
like from the social impact perspective,
the entire ALA group so
African Leadership Academy,
African Leadership University.
>> All of this started
up by Stanford alumn.
>> Then I can add two,
there's a solar company called
d.lights [INAUDIBLE] GSB alumn.
And then there's a pioneer high schools.
>> Yes, yes.
>> Yeah.
>> Picky [LAUGH]
>> And
maybe I can mention VC as well,
so I think Kev already
mentioned Savannah Fund
[INAUDIBLE] out of Tanzania.
[INAUDIBLE] that's an alumn and he's
focusing a lot on local entrepreneurs.
Which is a segment which is pretty much
ignored by the much of the VC funds.
And the other VC fund I can
mention is TL Cohen Capital
which has three GSB
alumns as partners there.
I think on the PE side,
it's a sector that there was a lot of
excitement in the mid to late 2000s.
And that has pretty much dipped now that
the developed markets
are performing better.
So there's a bit of negative
feeling there at the moment.
But if I think about it, there are still
the funds that are doing a good job.
It's pretty much the same names.
But I think
Development Partners International,
[INAUDIBLE] Of London has been
the best performing fund overall.
And maybe Helios is probably
the bigger brand [INAUDIBLE]
performance they should have led,
Helios, DPI, you can't go wrong.
I'm also looking at a couple
of funds like in London,
and ITO's out of South Africa that
met a couple of African MBAs.
Been turned down the other way
have a very good opinion of it.
And maybe just to go to the other end,
I think everyone looks
at the very big funds.
But there are some smaller funds
that have very good teams,
one of them run by GSB alumni.
It's a pretty decent team, so maybe not
that big in size, but a very decent team.
And playing in a very necessary
strategist of grid power.
>> Yeah.
>> I think one was Africa 15?
>> Casablanca, I think.
>> And I think the cool thing Going
quickly back to the company that
had been started by.
I think most or all of us here have had
the opportunity to interact with at least
two or three of these founders.
And I think coming to Stanford and
now understanding what leadership training
looks like, it's very clear that these
people were very positively impacted by
the leadership training that
you do get at Stanford.
Because the leadership style speaks to
a leader that you feel cares about you and
cares about the impacts,
just as much as they care about
building a successful company.
That's been my personal
experience with these alumni,
which was going back
to the first question,
one of the biggest reasons why I
personally chose to come to Stanford.
So we're going to take a question
from Kareem from Egypt.
So Kareem wants to travel to the United
States to visit Stanford University and
learn more about the MBA program and
the Stanford culture.
And his question is,
when would you recommend that he visit?
I would say that during the African
business forum clearly [LAUGH].
I don't know if you guys
have other answers.
>> It's also during spring, right?
>> Is also doing spring.
It's a beautiful time of year.
We'll give you more details on the African
Business Forum before this video is over,
but that's personally the best time to
come to Stanford, because you really get
to see how much the school has a play,
and has a stake on the continent.
You get to interact with a lot
of African students here.
You get to meet a lot
of amazing professors.
Spring is the time where people
are just generally more relaxed and
their classes are just more fun.
The sun's out, so yes, spring is
definitely the best time to come.
Anything else before I move on?
>> I have something to add.
Also, I don't want to feel like you should
come to see the campus before you apply.
>> Very good [INAUDIBLE].
>> I never came here to see the GSB and
it was a great decision nonetheless, so
don't feel obliged to come to
visit the campus if you can't.
>> Yeah, that's a good point.
>> If you're in the area,
if you want to come anyway, feel free,
that's a good decision, but
don't feel obliged to make the trip.
>> Yeah, that's such a great point,
because it doesn't do anything for
your application to come or
not to come, zero.
Your application to come or not to come
to the campus, so great point, Kevin.
So let's talk about this
question about Silicon Valley.
So Sadiq Goma wants to know
how involved are you guys,
if at all with Silicon Valley, and has it
been easy to promote African solutions and
raise funding, if you've tried or
if you know anybody who's tried?
>> I think, Silicon Valley, before I
came to Stanford, could feel like a very
nebulous concept of, what exactly
is Silicon Valley, where is it?
Is there a location, is there-
>> [LAUGH]
>> An area of land, Silicon Valley?
I think coming to Stanford,
I realized that Stanford and
Silicon Valley,
kind of you can't separate it.
Stanford is so embedded in Silicon Valley.
You're constantly exposed to
entrepreneurs, you're constantly exposed
to VC investors, all of the things
that makes Silicon Valley what it is.
Now the second question around raising
money as an African entrepreneur,
I personally haven't done it.
I know Kevin maybe can talk
a little bit more about this.
But I've spoken to African entrepreneurs
and there have been people that have been
very successful, like Kobo360
just raised a $30 million round,
people that are raising money I know that
sometimes it takes a little longer and
sometimes you need to
show a bit more traction.
But I'm encouraged by the fact that
quite a few people have done it and
it just seems to be on the rise here,
yeah.
>> Yeah, I also have been trying to
raise here, I'm not actively exploring
[INAUDIBLE], but I do know Africa and
raised funds whilst in school.
And one that comes to my mind is Nala,
who joined YC right after the GSB and
was able to raise some funds.
So it is doable.
I don't know if there's any Africans
in our class who've tried, or
even in the class above ours.
But looking broader at
the class in general,
there's a lot of people who have
raised funds for their companies.
So it's not.
>> I can also think
the person who probably
mentored me a lot when I was
applying to Stanford is from Kenya.
And I mean, I can't mention the company
because he is yet to officially launch it,
but I know he developed
the idea when he was here, and
the first investors in the fund
were a couple of his professors.
A lot of the Stanford professors
are venture capital investors and
they're always looking for
great ideas from students.
>> Yeah, and
I also think just building off of that,
Silicon Valley doesn't
also just look like VCs.
It looks like going to big tech and
working on emerging markets,
work within there.
I know, Lamiday worked at Luna,
I was at Google this summer.
And I was so immersed in all of
the different opportunities that Google
provides any employee who is interested
in pursuing some sort of initiative on
the continent, whether that's taking
a six-month externship just to pursue your
own idea within Google,
that's something that the company does.
I think other big tech companies do that.
Also, speaking of Nala and also speaking
of some Class of 2018 graduates
that I know, who also founded a company
in Kenya called Safi Analytics.
Silicon Valley can also look like some
of your friends and classmates who
are very interested in supporting what
you're doing both from a mentorship,
partnership perspective but sometimes
also from a financial perspective, too.
So, we'll take probably one more question,
and I love this question.
So this is from Ojoso Ankara, and
the question says, what would you say
stood out most in your application?
And what advice would you
give future applicants?
And before these three lovely people
answer, I would just like to preface
everything they say by,
everybody's application is very different.
You do not need to feel like you need to
copy somebody's specific application to
get there or that their application is the
best recipe for how to get to Stanford.
But I do think that everybody's story
matters and it helps you to kind of
understand people's experiences,
what they felt mattered to them
as they were going through
the process of applying to the GSB.
>> Thank you, so I think,
to me, I'm not 100% sure what
stood out in my application, but
if I was to reflect a little bit,
I think what matters to you the most
actually is a key part of the application.
And so how I thought of my application
is a portfolio of different things.
I used my resume,
used my recommendations to almost
tell the story of the achievements
that I had had thus far.
And then what matters to me, or
what matters to you the most, actually I
used it as an opportunity to just tell the
story of Lamide behind the achievements.
And it was just a very, I think,
very real raw essay about what matters to
me the most without judgment, just stating
it as it is, not trying to impress.
And I think that might have
been an ingredient, but
I would never know what
exactly got me here.
Yeah, I mean, it's really hard to know
unless you sit in that what they liked
about your application, but maybe if
I speak to what I think is different
in my profile and everyone has a map.
So I think most Africans have been to
only their country on the continent,
that's one thing, that most Africans
haven't traveled a lot in Africa.
And I had two jobs that
allowed me to travel so
much in many other African countries,
I think probably worked in almost 16
African countries on different projects.
And I think the depth at which I was able
to speak about African issues, I think,
is probably different from some others,
maybe just lived in one part of Africa.
I think that's something that came
out in my application Thinking,
I can't point to what I thought was
the most important part of my application,
from the school's perspective.
So I can't see what got me in.
But looking at it from my perspective,
at what I put in the most work in,
I think was the one with
the most essays will.
And why I say that is,
when I was have different versions of
essay at some point I did everything.
I started typing from
scratch super raw essay.
And I say tearing up when I was
typing it like yeah, this is me.
But I don't know if that's
what brought me in or not.
It might be something else.
But to me, that's what I felt was most
important for me in the application.
>> Yeah.
>> For me it was just my raw
intelligence and beauty.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Just kidding.
[LAUGH] No, is it that funny?
[LAUGH] No but I think similar to what
people are saying here I think our
applications made sense in terms of where
we're coming from and what we want to do.
And it probably showed a lot that
we thought really intentionally
about what we want to do with
a business degree at Stanford, and
why we want to do those things.
And so I think the biggest thing that I'm
getting from this panel is just the idea
of authenticity and
not feeling like you need to be somebody
different to get into Stanford.
Everybody talks about writing real and
raw essays and talking about your
actual experiences and that was
definitely my, my experience as well.
So we're going to take one more
sort of general question and
then we'll sort of close this out.
So we are getting a lot of questions about
what financially looks like at the GSB.
So I'll just kind of cap an umbrella
everything by saying, if you don't already
know the GSB offers need based fellowships
and not necessarily not merit merit based
fellowships, but the need based
fellowships are very generous and
are based on sort of an objectively
scaled system that the GSB runs.
Also there are other ways to find your
MBA program like the knight
Hennessy scholarship.
I know, for example, in Nigeria,
there are different organisations and
corporations that offer different
types of full scholarships.
I'm imagining that some may exist on
other countries on the continent, but
I would definitely say that the biggest,
one of the one of the best things I did
was having a mind switch and thinking
about the GSB from a debt perspective and
more from an investment perspective.
And I think that that just
helps you to ease your mind
because what you get by mere
default of being on this campus
is a huge investment that yield
opportunities for you for years to come.
But you can definitely
go on gsb.stanford.edu
to find out more about what
financial aid looks like for
you as an individual planning to apply for
next year, or the years to come.
So the last questions.
Our last group of questions I'm
getting actually have less to do with
student life.
People want to know what
student life is like culture.
What do you do on a typical
Thursday Friday, so
just, rapidly let's go about and
talk about maybe what your,
favorite pastime is or
something that's really fun for you.
I think we've talked about
a lot of serious things so
people want to know if you have fun or
not.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah, we have a lot of fun [LAUGH]
which is difficult since
the schedule is always super packed.
You mentioned like Thursday to me that
Thursday is my busiest day at 8am to 9pm
for classes and then there's beer
only after that, interesting.
So there's time to everything.
>> Yeah,
>> But I'm also a lot more introverted.
So I take time out to spend
time with myself like
watching shows just reflecting on
something that is looked at to happen.
I mean, it is business school,
there is always something [CROSSTALK]
how do you spread yourself across.
I probably had to make it to four
different events after 7 pm [CROSSTALK]
yesterday, I think the good thing
with Stanford if most of the first
year students leave right next to
the campus and to resume over the GSB.
So it's you get really
know each other and,
a lot of the things that are happening
are really close to you.
And I think that's the beauty
of being in California Ivy Tech,
one or two hour drive.
In whichever direction, there's a beach or
a mountain, people are always
planning those kinds of things.
And so that makes it really,
really really fun.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, and I think just add
to what these guys have said.
I think one thing that comes to mind for
me, I love the fact that in Stanford
you can really be who you are.
>> Exactly.
>> There's some people that love to
go to BPL every week or go to which
is like a huge party, and that's fine and
there's a community around that.
There are people like me who
are a little bit more introverted.
I like having people over for dinner or
watching movies with people in my house,
and that's perfectly fine too.
And there's no pressure to be either or
both are accepted and supported.
So that's what I've loved.
>> One thing for
me that I'll highlight is traveling.
>> That's true.
>> It's been such a fun experience
traveling with different classmates.
And I think some maybe a stereotype
about business schools is that you're
traveling to the amazing places in Asia,
Australia and all these places.
But people have very interesting
travel trips that they do.
Whether that's we're all going to
travel to Jordan to volunteer for
not for profit organization together.
Or we're going to travel to Cuba,
which was a really fun job.
Or we're going to go Go to New Zealand and
do really amazing things.
Or we're going to go to Austin,
Texas for South by Southwest,
which is a huge music festival
that happens every year.
People just find different
things that interest them.
Find groups of people
with similar interests.
Or people that are just
interested in traveling with you.
And that has been such an amazing fun
experience to really get off campus,
get out of the state sometimes.
Get to know people in
a very different space.
And really get to build what I would think
are some of the strongest bonds that
we can build with out classmates.
Not being in our element.
And fun is what you make it.
I think you can be in Vegas and not
have fun because you're a boring person.
Or you can be in your home
on a Saturday night and
having the best of fun because
you just make it that way.
So I would say that business
school in general is definitely
a place where you can have
as much fun as you want.
And still be as focused as you want.
And we can provide a little
bit more detail later.
[LAUGH].
As you guys start to apply.
So, I just wanted to make one
last comment, which is that
a lot of people want to know how they
can connect with African business club.
So you can connect with African business
club through the gsb.stanford.edu.
And like all of these
guys have mentioned and
I've also mentioned the Africa
Business Forum is really an event
that helps you to connect with us on
a really fun weekend in the spring.
It's happening April 11 this year, and
we're super excited because this forum
brings around some of the most intelligent
minds, thought partners, policy makers,
business moguls from the continent
to really come in and inspire and
challenge us here in the Bay Area,
in the center of Silicon Valley.
So we're super excited for the conference
to be held again in the spring this year,
so as we sort of come around to a close,
I wanted everybody just to go around and
give your words of wisdom to all of
the amazing people listening right now as
they're getting ready
to apply to Stanford.
It could be about anything you want
it to be, but what would you tell
hundreds of our listeners right now about
student life, applying to Stanford.
The best advice you can
give them anything.
I can start.
So I think one thing that
I did a lot was, even before
applying to Stanford, there was so
many times when I thought
I would never get in.
And I think a lot of people
don't even end up applying.
I know you guys on the call,
which is a step in the right direction.
But a lot of people ask us, these calls
I felt the same way, I'm just like,
I'm never going to get in.
And I find that African, not to generalize
Nigerian, specifically which I know.
People I've spoken to just
opt out to the process.
And think that I don't have the profile,
I haven't done anything amazing,
but I would just encourage
you to believe in yourself.
Apply, put your best foot forward,
reach out to any of us if you need help.
because we're all about getting
more Africans to come to GSP.
So, reach out to any of us if you need
help, please don't opt out by yourself.
>> I think when I say that there's
a lot of reasons not to apply.
And if you're going to look for
those reasons not to apply,
you'll find a lot of them.
And I did find a lot of them.
I remember one time,
reading just a list of pros and
cons of some probably that were not
even invited to interview at Stanford.
And I thought, what business do I
have applying in the first place?
So I think people are really different.
There's greatness in everyone, so
I think I just do some soul searching and
find that those that strength that you
haven't voted to bring to Stanford.
And focus on that and I'd say for
people worrying about am I
likely be able to afford it.
I'm saying focus on getting in and
you'll be surprised at how much,
how hard schools will work to make sure
you can afford it after you get admitted.
>> So, that was my first point.
>> [LAUGH]
>> My second one is If you're applying,
just be yourself.
Just be super authentic.
Don't try to be someone else.
As we've mentioned, everyone has
value they bring to this community.
Don't be afraid if you don't have
a background everyone else has.
Be comfortable in what you've done and
there's a place for it as well.
I echo everything they said.
So I just want to thank our
panelists Eugene, and Kevin for
taking time out of their
schedule to speak to you guys.
Feel free to reach out to
us at GSB.stanford.edu.
And we appreciate you guys so much.
We can't wait to see a lot of you guys,
a lot more of you guys in
the coming years at the GSB.
So thank you all very much.
[MUSIC]